this is not the onion version of the
david pakman show this is a real story
republican presidential nominee Donald
Trump suggested the possibility that gun
owners use their guns against Hillary
Clinton if she is indeed elected in
November this was at a campaign rally
yesterday in Wilmington North Carolina
you would think it was a fake story you
would say yeah the guy mock the disabled
reporter yeah the guy ridiculed the gold
star family whose son was killed in 2004
a fighting for the US military yeah the
guy suggests unconstitutional immoral
and unconscionable ideas all the time
but he wouldn't hint that his supporters
could maybe kill his opponent would he
yes he would take a look hillary wants
to abolish essentially abolish the
Second Amendment by the way and if she
gets to pick if she gets to pick her
judges nothing you can do folks although
the Second Amendment people maybe there
is i don't know but what I'll tell you
what that will be a horrible day hey
guys any day now Trump is going to pivot
to a softer more conciliatory tone
conciliatory tone just after he ends
with the suggestions of killing
political opponents he's really
resetting his campaign in an amazing way
shift away from the Muslim ban towards
killing your opponent even the Trump
supporter on stage there's a guy who all
point to if you're watching this guy
right here with the red shirt this guy
right here he looks stunned when Donald
Trump says this i'ma just replay a few
seconds of the Trump statement zoomed in
on this guy even the guy pick to be on
stage at a trump rally and you've gotta
be out of your mind in favor of Trump to
make it onto the stage at a rally he's
shocked take a look although the Second
Amendment people maybe there is our butt
but I'll tell you why that will be a
horrible day there is one other
possibility by the way unclear actually
whether he's shocked or thrilled and and
until elated by the by the suggestion
there's also the possibility that Trump
was suggesting not killing Hillary
Clinton but killing the judges that
Hillary Clinton would appoint way
different you know I guess advocate
the mass murder uh as opposed to just a
single assassination is a little bit
different it's uh it's not really now
it's the same what we're talking about
is just killing your political opponents
and uh yeah it's uh not going to change
a thing though for his is a staunch
supporter now if you're a supporter of
Trumpy what he already said I could
shoot people on Fifth Avenue it wouldn't
wouldn't change anything really true if
he suggesting other people shoot someone
why would that change anything now the
campaign has said oh all he was doing
was trying to activate voters to vote in
November for whom the Second Amendment
is important no the entire thing was if
Hillary wins in November then XYZ will
happen if you're talking about something
that will happen if Hillary wins after
the election and what people might do
you can't then say what I was actually
doing was trying to encourage people to
vote now this is a good time for me to
introduce or reintroduce the term
stochastic terrorism now stochastic is a
term that's often used in investing
right in stocks it sort of means
randomly determined having a random
probability but distribution or pattern
which we could analyze statistically but
we couldn't predict precisely so like
for example if I said to you x percent
of stocks statistically and
probabilistically speaking over the next
10 years will go up by two thousand
percent right we know that some stocks
probably will but we have really no way
of predicting exactly which stocks those
are it applies to what Donald Trump is
doing in that the general suggestion of
using guns against Hillary Clinton or
against her Supreme Court nominees or
whoever statistically speaking because
of the size of trumps platform it could
well lead to someone being inspired by
what he said to actually go and kill a
judge or try to kill Hillary Clinton
hopefully the Secret Service would be
would be able to protect her but it's
completely unpredictable who it would be
but once you get to large enough numbers
these are not words that have no meaning
and that's how the term stochastic
terrorism applies here Louis we know
that Trump's rhetoric months ago uh the
the the semi tone down rhetoric back
then was enough to lead p
to beating up our black people at Trump
rallies yeah so imagine what this type
of of rhetoric can do I wasn't imagining
that within two weeks those horrible
comments about gold star dad Kazakh on
and deceased army captain who my Yoon
Khan would seem relatively innocuous as
offensive as they were but we kinda have
to hand it to trump Lewis he's come up
with something so much more outrageous
that the entire Khan scandal seems
relatively tame compared to the UH
implicit suggestion that you kill his
opponent hehe steps it up every week
every week he says something more
outrageous than than the week before and
I'm wondering where he hits the wall
right where does this end our supporters
ready to stop saying well Trump didn't
really mean it when he says ban Muslims
he's he just kind of saying it it's not
really anything that will have an impact
what's Paul Ryan going to say now while
I don't agree with Trump suggesting his
supporters assassinate Hillary Clinton I
still support him in our party as the
Republican nominee this is a campaign in
chaos and imagine being Secret Service
you're paid to protect both candidates
and one is making comments that could
endanger the other it is a very very
weird time to be following politics and
we will talk to Bill share about it a
little bit later